لا أعرف ما هي
[موسيقى]
أه
أهلاً
[موسيقى]
ما نراه
هو
مجموعات من المدنيين المعتقلين الذين
تم القبض عليهم وسيروا نحو
حفرة إعدام معصوبي الأيدي
وقيل لهم أن يركضوا وهم يركضون ، تم إطلاق النار
عليهم من قبل ضابط مخابرات
سوري كان يقف بالقرب منه اسمه
أمجد يوسف
[موسيقى
] لقد شاهدت الكثير من الفظائع التي تم تصويرها على
الكاميرا
ولكن هذا الفيلم على وجه الخصوص صدمني
مثل قلة آخرين  الاستعداد
الذي
يسير به هؤلاء الضحايا نحو موتهم
[موسيقى]
أه
ما نأمله هو أن يبدأ هذا الفيديو وغيره من مقاطع الفيديو
التي قد تظهر في
إضفاء بعض الإحساس بالعدالة على
الآلاف من العائلات التي
لا تزال تبحث عن  أحبائهم
الذين ما زالوا لا يعرفون ما إذا كانوا
في سجن أو في قبر أو يحتمل أن يكونوا في
فترة إعدام
أجنبية
[موسيقى]